alors on va commencer avec les nouvelles
méthodes pour trouver du travail nous
sommes difficiles confinement alors
c'est compliqué pour tous mais surtout
pour ceux qui cherchent des petits jobs
notamment les étudiants qui sont en fin
d'études etc
avec maintenant c'est impossible on peut
parler dans les restaurants etc et il ya
une nouvelle méthode pour trouver du
boulot c'est c'est via victhom
on a tous des cantiques et voici le
récap cette période est compliquée pour
tout le monde et surtout pour ceux qui
cherchent du boulot avec le couvre-feu
ou le confinement
l'économie est loin de bien se porter et
les opportunités pour trouver un emploi
sont minces enfin une piste pourtant
certains essayent de trouver des
solutions
comme cette boulangerie qui a décidé de
publier sur les emballages de ses
baguettes des offres d'emploi à
proximité il y avait mes canons un essai
en oeuvre un grouillait une façon de
diffuser l'information dans toute la
région facilement et surtout pour les
clients de repartir avec un pain de
campagne et peut-être un cdi et
puisqu'il est difficile de se déplacer
des petits malins ont déduit que la
solution se trouvait peut-être sur
internet et plus précisément sur le
réseau social qui fait fureur chez les
jeunes tik tok un réseau dédié au
divertissement et à la danse mais qui
dans cette période peut servir pour
publier des petites annonces une période
particulière qui montre bien que la
société est capable de s'adapter à
toutes les situations même les pires
[Musique]
jamais créé une plateforme qui permet
justement d'essayer de trouver un petit
boulot d'art déjà commencé et ai dit
vous est venue alors m'est venue déjà
par expérience personnelle où on a tout
subi des fois des périodes où on avait
du mal à trouver du travail et en plus
de ça de la situation actuelle en fait
où beaucoup de jeunes ou demandeurs
d'emploi ont du mal à trouver parce que
il ya moins d'offres x est plus
difficile que de prospecter donc j'ai
voulu participer à ma manière à aider la
société de cette manière alors qu'est ce
que ça change de passer par les réseaux
partick top pour passer une petite
annonce alors ça change beaucoup de
choses des gens n'ont pas besoin de se
rencontrer on se différencient parce
qu'aujourd'hui
faut faire la différence un cv ou un
autre le recruteur il peut avoir les
mêmes compétences sûrs d'eux mêmes cv ce
qui va faire qu'il va vous retenir c'est
ce que vous dégagez et la vidéo c'est la
mer c'est le meilleur moyen pour
défendre vous avez des exemples de ce
qu'il faut pas faire oui vous n'y
arrivez alors c'est ça on va regarder et
regarder tout ça
enfin regardez bonjour j'ai pris fritter
toi qui cherche l'homme de la situation
l'homme pour faire la malle à l'homme tu
veux faire la bringue nom qui va à
demi-mot de nuit bonduelle espère
installer pas croyable mais voilà la
maladie
bon ça c'est pas pour ça on n'apprend
rien ne va pas se mentir c'est voilà
alors il ya une bonne version et ça ça
ressemble à ça regardez jour je
m'appelle jan sainte rose j'ai 26 ans et
je réside à asnières sur seine dans les
hauts seine actuellement concernant ne
sont pas très loin de ça de l'union
financière de france
je suis ouvert aux opportunités d'emploi
sur le secteur de la banque assurance
mais plus généralement de la finance de
l'immobilier et de l'automobile et 33
des secteurs qui me passionne tout
particulièrement de nature sociable et
ambitieuse et reconnu pour mon travail
rigoureux j'aime travailler au sein
d'une équipe et fédérer cette dernière
n'hésitez pas à prendre contact avec moi
très rapidement via mes coordonnées sur
mon profil ruth flint je me ferais un
plaisir d'échanger avec vous sur n'ont
pas couru
alors ça c'est la même personne au bout
on a compris mais l'accès très seul rien
du coup quand on a reçu la vidéo on a eu
1 le contraste est là c'est la wii voilà
c'est ça donc on l'a contacté veut qu'on
propose également un service de coaching
en fait aujourd'hui pour effectivement
réussir à faire la différence lors des
entretiens alors le la plate forme
s'appelle recrute link recrue link
recrue link c'est ça alors on a un
exemple d'une personne qui a postulé
pour rentrer au psg
l'annoncé de pouvoir donner suite
favorable à votre candidature
alors qu'est-ce qu'il allait demander
comme les jouets les gauches évidemment
c'est non ça se fait pas comme ça quand
même
c'est un peu compliqué je pense que le
cadeau suprême au triage où vous jouez
vous jurer avoir mis trois but en 20
minutes lors du derby en 2008 2018 et
avoir mis à vous tout seul un énorme
grâce aux portugais grignan 2010
compromis au regard de votre âge de 42
ans
il en tête baissée le rugby déplaçant
pour le prochain match et où il a quand
même il est parti avec deux places
encore alors aujourd'hui pour ceux qui
nous regardent piron qui ont amendé
galère pour trouver du boulot
et dieu sait que c'est très compliqué en
ce moment quels sont les conseils que
vous pouvez donner tout de suite alors
déjà avoir un cv un jour parce que on
oublie souvent une bonne présentation et
surtout aujourd'hui en fait la
différence qu'on veut faire bonne
impression à quelqu un espace en 20
secondes les vingt premières secondes il
faut qu'on soit très bon dans les 20
premiers gestes les 20 premiers mots
qu'on va citer et la première impression
c'est la bonne c'est celle que le
recteur va l'obtenir
donc c'est très important de travailler
ces vingt premières secondes la en
entretien yao ddd des recruteurs qui
disait en 20 secondes c'est bon je n'en
veux pas alors c'est pas forcément ses
passes et palourdes en seconde main
pourquoi donc c'est vrai totalement
raison vous êtes totalement raison moi
je sais que pour des recrutements par
exemple dans les vingt premières
secondes on regarde l'attitude de la
personne sait s'exprimer si elle a des
mots qui sont conformes enfin voir si
tout ce passe et tout de suite on sait
si on recrute pas ce que vous revenez
jamais retenu c'est pour ça que c'est
moi qui recrutent c'est la baule avant
tout les remercie beaucoup
j'apparais joue super idée je rappelle
le batteur on sert qu aux crues ont
accru les rings merci beaucoup
m